gençler Merhaba hepiniz hoş geldiniz
ikinci tema organizasyon konusuna
başlıyoruz Tabii ki biz bu iki videoda
bugünkü iki videoda inorganik
bileşiklerden su ve mineralleri
inceleyeceğiz Sizden ricam şu aşağıya
açıklama kısmına su ve minerallerle
alakalı tyt gruplarına ne anlattığımı
gösteren videoların linkini bırakıyorum
çekinmeden izleyin Sizler Zeki
çocuklarsınız sakın konudan korkmayın
konu sizden Korksun temel prensipler
Zaten orada da burada da aynı buradaki
fark ne biz ne yapıyoruz map kitabını
tarıyoruz ve MEB kitabındaki
çalışmaları uygulaya uygulaya
ilerliyoruz Ama o kısımda özellikle ne
olacak arkadaşlar daha çok sorulara
yönelik yani bize ne sorulabilir Ne
sorulursa neyin üzerinden sorulabilir
tarzında aslında konu anlatım
videolarıyla karşılaşacaksınız Bu
videomuzda hemen girişte size su ve
öneminden bahsedeceğim O zaman ne
diyoruz Hadi gelin birlikte
öğrenelim ne demiş kitabımız inorganik
moleküller hücrelerdeki biyokimyasal
reaksiyonların gerçekleşmesinde oldukça
önemli görevlere sahip şimdi Mantık
olarak su tepkimelerin gerçekleşebilmesi
için bir ortam yaratıyor O yüzden
ileride enzimler diye bir konu
öğreneceksiniz Enzim nedir biyokimya al
tepkimelerin gerçekleşmesi için gerekli
olan aktivasyon enerjisi engelini
rahatça açmamızı sağlayan biyolojik
katalizörler Yani aslında Şimdilik
hızlandırıcı olarak bilebilirsiniz şimdi
Enzimlerin çalışabilmesi için ortamda
belirli bir su konsantrasyonu olması
lazım ve aynı zamanda bazı enzimler
bileşik enzimler yapılarında yardımcı
gruplar kofaktörler bulundurabilir
Bunlar da çoğunlukla minerallerdir yani
hocam Bazen bu hız hızlandırıcı Madde
olan Enzimlerin çalışabilmesi için neye
ihtiyaç varmış doğrudan minerallere
ihtiyaç var işte O yüzden Arkadaşlar bu
cümle önemli reaksiyonların
gerçekleşeceği ortamı sağlayan sudur Ve
tabii ki bu durumda su yaşam için
vazgeçilmez bir bileşik oluyor o yüzden
işte bilim insanları uzayda bir şey
keşfettiklerini Bir de hadi Bakalım
burada sua var mı canlılık için uygun
bir ortam mı şeklinde bir soru
soruyorlar Ama tabii ki her canlı için
su şart mıdır bilmiyoruz Belki de dünya
dışındaki varlıklar için konuşuyorum
Tabii ki onlar başka bir kimyasal
maddeye adapte olmuştur Ama biz
Öncelikle bildiğimiz canlılar üzerinden
gittiğimiz için suyun önemini birinci
sıraya koyuyoruz Bir de organik
bileşikler imiz olacak proteinler
lipitler karbohidrat gibi bunlar da
temelde bizim yapımızı oluşturan ve aynı
zamanda solunum tepkimelerinde enerji
elde etmemizi sağlayan temel bileşenler
olacak arkadaşlar hücrelerden ileride
bahsedeceğiz hücre zarı sitoplazma
çekirdek organel gibi yapılardan
bahsedeceğiz hücre zarında özellikle
Difüzyon aktif taşıma kolaylaştırılmış
Difüzyon osmos gibi olaylar olacak
bunlar nedir hocam bunlar hücrenin dış
ortamdan madde alışverişini sağlayan ya
da içerideki Bir maddeyi dışarı atmayı
sağlayan yollardan bazıları Şimdilik
Sadece duymuş olun arkadaşlar biyolojik
organizasyon basamaklarını basitten
karmaşa hatırlayalım hücreler dokuları
dokular organları organlar sistemleri
sistem ise organizmanın kendisini
meydana getiriyordu Tabii vücudumuzda
nükleik asitler var bilginin
aktarılmasını sağlayan
dna'mızda proteinler enzim olabilir
hormon olabilir enerjinin çoğunluğunun
depolanmasında görevli yağlar mesela
deri altında yağ biriktiriyoruz bunlara
trigliserit nötral yağlar diyeceğiz
Bunlar hem ısı izolasyonu sağlayacak hem
de bize enerji verecek mesela Kalbimizin
etrafında Çok ciddi bir yağ katmanı
vardır Neden Çünkü Kalbimiz Yağ
asitlerinden enerji üretmeyi sever çünkü
hocam yağ asitleri çok enerji verir
diyeceğiz ileride yine hızlı enerji
dönüşümlerinde etkili olan
Karbonhidratlar neden hızlı Enerji
dönüşümü demiş biliyor musunuz Çünkü
Karbonhidratlar vücudumuzun birinci
derece enerji kaynağıdır Yani önce
Karbonhidratlar yıkılır Hatta beynimizin
temel enerji kaynağı 6 karbonlu bir
şeker olan Glukoz Tamam bunları her
zaman ne diyorum sarmal model
uyguluyorum 5 ders 6 ders sonra
göreceğiniz şeylere Şimdiden sizi
ısıtmaya çalışıyorum ama dikkat edin
dediğimde İşte o cümle Bu dersi
ilgilendirir anlamına gelir Peki bunlar
organik moleküllerde bunların yanı sıra
inorganik moleküller yer alır dedik su
mineral tuz L İnorganik moleküllerdir ve
geldi bir yıldız bakın genellikle karbon
içermeyen moleküller inorganiktir Ancak
şöyle bir çıkarımda sakın bulunmayın her
karbon içeren organik bileşik midir
Hayır hocam Hemen buraya yazalım cevap
kocaman bir hayır Mesela karbonmonoksit
karbondioksit Siyanür vesaire Bunlar
inorganiktir o zaman inorganikler için
şöyle bir cümle kurabilir miyim
genellikle karbon içermeyen organikler
için de İleride işte karbon hidrojen
oksijen içeren bileşikler şeklinde bir
tanım yapmaya çalışacağız geldim şimdi
su inorganik moleküllerin en önemlisi
doğada ve organizmaların yapısında en
çok bulunan madde işte arkadaşlar buna
Yıldız atmanızı istiyorum çünkü bu
sorgulanıyor yani hangi molekül
miktarına göre daha fazladır işte
inorganik bileşikler içerisinde su ama
bariz bir şekilde totale de vurduğumuzda
vücudumuzun % 70'i su dünyaya da
baktığınızda arkadaşlar çok ciddi bir su
kütlesi var karadan daha fazla ancak
Kafanız karışmasın Eğer cümle şöyle
gelirse Vücudumuzda en fazla bulunan
organik bileşik kimdir derse birisi o
zaman cevaba protein yazabilirsiniz
organik inorganik ayrımı yapmayıp
Vücudumuzda en çok bulunan bileşik su
ama organik vurgusu yaparsa su organik
değil su inorganiktir Biz bugün
inorganik bileşik olarak su ve
minerallerden bahsedeceğiz Peki suyun
nasıl özellikleri var birkaç defa
söyleyeceğim bunu suyun çözücü özelliği
var ne işimize yarıyor Hocam bu kimya
değil mi Bak şimdi eğer bir madde suda
çözülebiliyorsa normal ve rahat bir
şekilde taşınabilir anlamına gelir ve
bizim kanımız % 0 sudur Dolayısıyla Biz
suda çözemediğimiz Bir maddeyi kanımızla
taşıyamayız Bu bir cepte ikincisi Eğer
Bir maddeyi suda çözemezsen bunu
vücuttan atamazsınız Bu bir yerde gider
birikir çöker o yüzden bir madde
gibi bileşenlerle beraber vücuttan
dışarı atılacak yani metabolik atıkların
uzaklaştırılmasında da su yardımcı
metabolik reaksiyonların gerçekleşmesi
mantığını enzimler için bir çalışma
ortamı bir ortam sağlıyor ki sitoplazma
biliyorum ki çok büyük oranda sudan
meydana geliyor vücut sıcaklığının
düzenlenmesi mesela hocam terleme
mantığı terlediğimiz zaman ne oluyor su
Derimizin üzerinden sıcaklığı alıyor ve
buharlaşıyor ve ÖSYM sorularından bir
tanesi işte öz ısı buharlaşma ısısı
suyun öz ısısı yüksektir suyun
buharlaşma ısısı yüksektir buharlaşma
ısısını terlemeyle soğutma özelliği ile
ilişkilendirebiliriz öz ısıyı ise geç
ısınır geç soğur Okyanus kenarlarındaki
Deniz kenarlarındaki şehirlerin bir anda
soğumaması ya da bir anda ısınmamasının
sebebi de budur Çünkü su kendi
içerisinde çok yüksek miktarda ısıyı
barındırabilir hapsedecek
Hani o bölgelerin ılıman bir iklime
sahip olması da bundan dolayıdır
sindirim sürecinde önemli rol üstlenir
ileride şöyle bir kelime daha
öğreneceksiniz hidroliz hidroliz hidros
su Liz parçalamak Lizozom kelimesinden
geliyor öyle aklınızda tutun ya da litik
parçalama su ile parçalama büyük
molekülleri su ile kendisini oluşturan
küçük moleküllere kadar
parçalayabilir de yapacağız y Yani
kısacası canlı Yaşamının devamlılığı
suyun varlığına bağlıdır şimdi buraya
şöyle bir cümle yazdım birkaç yerde
gördüğüm için şimdiden duyun duyun duyun
sürekli tekrar edin bir mineralin
eksikliği bir başka mineralle
giderilemez yani hocam bugün Demir
almayayım kalsiyumu yeterince Aldım
zaten kalsiyum demirin işini yapar
diyemezsiniz bunu araya böyle bir bilgi
olarak attım birkaç defa daha
söyleyeceğim neden hocam Çünkü her
mineralin vücutta görev aldığı bir yer
var yani kalsiyum mesela kas kasılması
kemik gelişimi kanın pıt laşmak görev
alırken Demir mesela vücudumuzda
oksijenin taşınmasında görev alıyor
Şimdi kalsiyuma gitsen oksijen taşı
diyebilir misin diyemem hocam o yüzden
demir eksikliğinde mesela İnsanlar ne
oluyor anemi oluyor kalsiyum
eksikliğinde ne oluyor kemik erimesi
oluyor bakın her birinin eksikliğinde
bambaşka hastalıklar ortaya çıkıyor
bunların görevleri birbirine
devredilemez Aslında bunu şöyle
bağlamanız istiyorum bakın Biraz detay
derin düş düşünelim dersin başında dedim
ki bazı enzimler yardımcı grup olarak
mineral alırlar Mesela bir a enzimi
şöyle görselleştirme bir a enzimi var
diyelim ki bu A enzimi demirle çalışıyor
Eğer ortamda demir olmazsa a enzimi
çalışır mı çalışmaz enzim neydi hocam
enzim tepkimeyi hızlandıran maddeyi
bileşik enzimlerde de yan Grup yardımcı
grup olarak mineral bulunabilirdi ya da
b enzimi mesela gider kalsiyumla çalışır
demirle çalışmaz Siz buna kalsiyumu
bırak demir al diyemezsiniz Tamam o
yüzden bir mineralin eksikliğini bir
başka mineral gideremez ve burada bir
tablo bu tabloyu Video izledikten sonra
dolduruyorsunuz ama ben size hemen şimdi
özet yapayım şimdi mineraller arkadaşlar
canlılar tarafından üretilemez herkes
minerali doğadan hazır almak zorundadır
Yani bir bitki Demir üretemez Kalsiyum
üretemez magnezyum üretemez Ama hocam
bir sürü besin üretiyor Tamam besin
üretebilir karbohidrat lipit protein
vitamin bunları üretebilir bunları İşte
o mineralleri kullanarak üretecek ben o
yüzden bunu toprağa koyuyorum bu bitkiyi
toprağa ekiyorum Ama hocam toprağa
ekmediğin işte Sudaki bitkiler de var
ama o da sudan alıyor mineralini
Dolayısıyla mineralleri Her canlı
dışarıdan hazır alır Arkadaşlar kimse
mineral üretemez canlılar tarafından
mineraller sindirilmez yani demiri nasıl
sindirecek değil mi magnezyumu Nasıl
sindirecek bunu olduğu gibi hücre
zarından direkt geçer ve ilgili bölgeye
gider enerji verici olarak kullanılmaz
tabii ki burada dikkat etmemiz gereken
bir şey var Solunumda ifadesini
kullanmam lazım Solunumda karbohidrat
lipit protein kullanır neden hocam
solunum diye vurgulamak zorunda kaldın
bunu arkadaşlar 12 sınıfa bırakalım
tamam mı O kadar da değil hücre zarından
geçer sindirilmez dedik canlı yapısına
katılır hocam Bizim zaten büyük oranda
sudan oluştuğu biliyorsun peki
Mineraller nasıl yapıya Katılıyor mesela
hormonların yapısına katılır birazdan
söyleyeceğim tiroksin mesela
metabolizmamız üzerinde hızlandırıcı
etkiye sahip hormon yapısında iyot var
ya da Demir hemoglobin dediğimiz çok
önemli bir protein olan kan proteini
yani oksijen karbondioksit Taşıyan
proteinin yapısında bulunuyor demir gibi
bir sürü arkadaşlar örnek verebiliriz
Hücre zarının yapısında mesela
fosfolipit katman olacak bakın fosfat
flor dişlerin yapısına katılacak işte
kalsiyum kemiklerin yapısına katılacak
gibi gibi gibi yaşamsal faaliyetlerin
düzenlenmesinde görev alır ne dedik
hocam Enzimlerin çalışması için uygun
bir ortam sağlayan su vardı ve bazı
Enzimlerin ya da bazı hormonların
yapısına katılan mineraller vardı gibi
cevaplar verebilirsiniz Bu şekilde size
sarıya boyayarak Arkadaşlar doğru cevabı
göstermeye çalıştım şimdi suya biraz
detaylı bakalım dünyanın işte çok büyük
bir yüzdesi su ile kaplı vücudumuzun da
arkadaşlar büyük bir yüzdesi suyla kaplı
ancak bu kadar çok su sizi yanıltmasın
bunun sadece % 3 % 5'lik kısmı tatlı su
yeraltı suyu yani kullanılabilir
içilebilir su Geriye kalanlar içilemez
suyunu içemezsin arkadaşlar Çünkü Deniz
suyunun tuzluluk oranı kanımızdan çok
çok daha yüksek Dolayısıyla Bizim onu
vücuttan
atabilmek bir kişi daha çok susar ve o
onun ölümüne neden olur Şimdi suyun
yapısına baktığımız zaman şöyle iki tane
hidrojen bir tane oksijen görüyorsunuz
ve oksijenin üzerinde ortaklanmamış
elektronlar olacak bunu tabii kimyaya
bırakıyoruz Ama bu neden önemli bizde
Çünkü yüklü bir yapı polar bir yapı
oluşturuyor su polar poları apolar
apoları çözer mantığı buradan çıkıyor ve
hocam Bizim kanımız su yani polar bir
madde Dolayısıyla apolar olan maddeler
kanımızda çözülemez mesela yağı öyle
kafamıza göre kanda taşıyamıyor ama işte
şeker ne yapıyor suda çözündüğü gibi
gibi kanımızın içerisinde de çözünerek
taşınabiliyor dolayısıyla Benzer benzeri
çözer ilkesine vurgu yapabilmek için bu
bilgi önemli tabii burada suyun adezyon
kohezyon yüksek ısı kapasitesi
ifadelerini öğreteceğim size Az önce
yüksek ısı kapasitesinden bahsettim işte
Deniz kenarları ve okyanus
kenarlarındaki şehirlerin ılıman iklime
sahip olması aslında Suyun ısı
kapasitesi ile alakalı Peki adhezyon ve
kohezyon ne adhezyon yapışma kohezyon
ise çekim anlamına geliyor Arkadaşlar bu
şekilde düşünebilirsiniz şimdi bir
kalsın Bakalım burada bir etkinliğimiz
var laml Birinin üzerine birkaç damla su
koyunuz ve ikinci lam birincinin üzerine
yavaşça yerleştirerek suyun ince bir
tabaka haline gelmesini bekleyiniz
ardından iki lamı birbirinden ayırmaya
çalışınız burada ne olacak arkadaşlar
işte suyun yapıştırıcı özelliği Ortaya
çıkacak Yani adhezyon özelliği az önce
ne dedim ben bir su molekülü ile başka
bir madde arasında çekim kuvvetine
adezyon denir mesela suyun cama
yapışması bir
adezyondan şu şekilde damlamak üzere
olan bir suyun bakın musluğa yapışmasını
sağlayan buradaki kuvvet adezyon
kuvvetidir Ama bu damlanın şeklinin
oluşmasını sağlayan kuvvet nedir İşte o
da su su moleküllerinin birbirini
çekmesi bakın bir su molekülü hidrojeni
ile diğer Su molekülünün oksijeni
arasındaki şu hidrojen bağını da
oluşturan böyle Hidrojen bağı yazalım
kohezyon kuvvetidir arkadaşlar kohezyon
kohezyon kuvveti bir yüzey gerilim
kuvvetidir böceklerin su üzerinde
durmasını sağlayan bitkilerin topraktan
su çekmesini sağlayan esas kuvvetlerden
bir tanesidir defalarca söyleyeceğim
merak etmeyin bakın su dolu bardağın
içerisine para madeni para atılıyor
atılıyor atılıyor atılıyor atılıyor en
son şöyle suyun üzerinde şöyle
Arkadaşlar bir katman bir film oluşur
bakın bardağın üstünde kavisli bir yapı
oluşuyor ya o kavisli Yapı işte su su
moleküllerinin birbirini çekmesi sonucu
oluşan kohezyon kuvvetidir buz
küplerinin su yüzeyinde durmasının ve
buz küpleri eridiğinde suyun taşmaması
Nedenini açıklayınız biraz fizik bu
artık ama biz ne diyoruz Öncelikle buzun
öz kütlesi D buz küçüktür D su doğru mu
o yüzden siz buzu suya attığınız zaman
buz yüzer peki bunun biyolojiyle ne
alakası var hocam çok alakası var
nehirler denizler Göller okyanuslar
yüzeyden donar arkadaşlar Dolayısıyla
alttaki canlılık devam eder Eğer böyle
bir özelliği olmasaydı diğer maddeler
gibi su da katısı sıvısında batan bir
madde olsaydı ne olacaktı sular dipten
donacak ve canlılık kalmayacaktı Hocam
bu nasıl olabilir ki buzul çağı dünyadan
bir buzul çağı geçti değil mi ve böyle
olmaması ile beraber bir de ısı yalıtımı
sağlamış oluyorsunuz Siz buzun su
üzerinde yüzmesi yani Öz kütlesinin
sıvısından daha küçük olması yaşamsal
olarak bakın bizi nereye götürüyor Deniz
Göl Okyanus gibi ortamlar yüzeyden
donmuş alttaki canlılık devam etmiş
hocam Peki neden taşmaz o fizik artık
batan hacmi kadar sıvı Taşırır vesaire
gibi cümlelere girip biyolojinin
içerisine çok da fizik katmak
istemiyorum ama nedir hocam Evet eğer şu
şekilde buzları koydunuz belli bir
yüksekliğe ulaştı bu H kadar buz
eridiğinde yine H kadar olacaktır
yükseklik şimdi Karabiberi suyun üzerine
döktüğünüz de karabiber çok hafif olduğu
için suyun üzerinde duracak Yani aslında
Suyun oluşturduğu o kohezyon kuvveti
sayesinde o film gibi bir tabakanın
üzerinde karabiberler böyle çok hafif
olduğu için üstte kalacak parmağınızı
yavaşça suya dokundurdu ama şeyi hareket
ettirmemenin lazım bardağı yavaşça suya
dokundurdu su yüzey gerilimi
bozulmayacağını
parmağınız suya tam batmayacak ve
dolayısıyla parmağınız suyla doğrudan
temas etmediği için ıslanmayacak
şeklinde yorum yapacaksınız Burada da
genel geçer ifadeler içine bazı maddeler
koyun alerjiniz yoksa Tadına bakın gibi
bir Eee çalışma şimdi adhezyon ve
kohezyon Ben adhezyon deme sebebim
arkadaşlar orijinali burada bir h harfi
var aslında çözümlerde de bulmaca
çözümlerinde adhezyon olarak yazmış
kitabımız ama çözümün kendisinde
bulmacada H harfini koymamışlar çok
önemli değil öğretmenimiz ne diyorsa
odur arkadaşlar yani biz sınıfta Ne
yazıyorsak o olmalı tamam mı adezyon
farklı moleküllerin birbirini çekmesiyle
külüyle Suyun dışında başka bir molekül
işte su damlasının cama yapışması ya da
az önceki verdiğim örneği burada tekrar
edeyim çeşmeden damlamak üzere olan bir
damlanın Çeşmeye yapışması bu işte
adezyonda aynı tür moleküllerin birbiri
arasındaki çekim kuvvetini ifade ediyor
Yani bizim için kohezyon nedir Tekrar
hocam hatırlayalım bir su Molekülün
hidrojeni ile diğer Su molekülünün
oksijeni arasındaki çekim kuvveti Yani
aslında burası hidrojen bağıdır kimyada
Biz hidrojen bağını f o yani hidrojenin
flor oksijen ve azotla yaptığı bağ
olarak öğreniyoruz fon bileşikleri
vesaire gibi kısaltması vardı
hatırlarsanız ya da en azından
öğreneceksiniz Şimdi suyun bir araya
gelerek bir damla oluşturması bakın Az
önce verdiğim örnek burada Dolu bir
tüpün ağzında bombe oluşması kohezyon
örneğidir suyun köklerden yukarı
taşınmasında suyun adhezyon ve kohezyon
özelliği vardır kullanılır nedir hocam
su bitkinin içerisinde yükselirken bitki
hücresindeki çepere yapışır E bir de suu
molekülleri birbirini çekiyordu Bu da
kohezyon yapışma adhezyon birbirini
çekmesi kohezyon Demek ki bitkinin suyu
köklerinden Yaprakların uç kısmına kadar
taşımasında temelde adhezyon kohezyon
gibi kuvvetler rol alıyor arkadaşlar
Peki bu kohezyon neydi Aslında yüzey
gerilimi olarak adlandırılıyordu
Dolayısıyla bakın böceklere böcekler
suyun üzer
durabiliyorlar Neden Çünkü Hocam bakın
şu cümle çok kıymetli belki de doğrudur
yanlıştır sorusu bile olabilir su
molekülleri arasındaki kohezyon kuvveti
böcek ayağı ve su arasındaki adhezyon
kuvvetinden büyüktür yani yüzeydeki o
film o yüzey
gerilimi böceğin suya bastığı zaman
yaratacağı o Baskıdan basınçtan daha
güçlü O yüzden böcek ne yapıyor suyun
üzerinde duruyor ne önemi var hocam
bunlar için Habitat neydi Bir canlının
yaşayıp
üreyebilir suyun üzerinde beslenirler
ürerler vesaire polar bir çözücü olan
suyun içerisinde pek çok madde yüksek
oranda çözünebilir çözünebilir ki biz de
onu taşıyabiliyor birçok maddeyi kan
dolaşımında taşıyacağız kimyasal
tepkimelerin gerçekleşmesinde besinlerin
taşınmasında hücresel yapıların
korunmasında Hayati önemli görevler
üstlenir defalarca söyledik çözücülük
özelliği sayesinde topraktaki mineraller
alıyor Çünkü mineraller tuzlar tuz
şeklinde ne yapıyor hocam suyun
içerisine çözünüyor ve canlı suyu
aldığında Saf su almıyor içerisinde
mineral olan suyu almış oluyor bakın ısı
kapasitesini sıcaklık değişimlerine
karşı dirençli olmasını sağlayan bu
özellik canlıları ani sıcaklık
değişimlerine karşı korur yani mevsim
geçişlerinin daha yavaş olmasının sebebi
o deniz kenarındaki ya da Okyanus
kenarındaki şehirlerin işte suyun
arkadaşlar ısı kapasitesinin
yüksek olması daha somut hale getireyim
size ben mesela diyelim ki bir ortam çok
ısındı O çok ısındığı zaman ne oluyor
biliyor musunuz Hani az önce susu
molekülleri arasında bir çekim kuvveti
vardı o hidrojen bdı İşte o ısı
Arkadaşlar şu bağın kopmasını sağlıyor E
böyle bir sürü trilyonlarca bağ var
Dolayısıyla su o ısıyı bir şekilde içine
hapsetmiş oluyor tam tersi mantığı
düşünelim Nasıl ki bir bağı kopartmak
için enerjiye ihtiyacınız var O zaman
bağ oluşurken de açığa enerji çıkar
ortam aşırı soğuduğunda su su
molekülleri arasında kurulan yeni
hidrojen bağlarıyla açığa q kadar bir
enerji çıkacak Ve o da ortamın
ısınmasını sağlayacak bakın geçiş ne
oldu yumuşak bir hale geldi düşük
sıcaklıkta katılaşan suyun yoğunluğu
sıvı halden daha düşük Soğuk havalarda
su yüzeyi buzla Kaplanı oldu Hem dipten
donmaya canlılığın devam etmesini
sağlıyorsun hem de bir yandan ısı
izolasyonu sağlamış oluyorsun Evet suyun
arkadaşlar öneminden bahsettik gözümüze
çarpan kelimeler adhezyon kohezyon ısı
kapasitesinin yüksek olması iyi Bir
çözücü olması ve katısının sıvısında
yüzüyor olması bu beş kelimeye dikkat
edeceğiz Elbette ki çok fazla görevi var
tepkimeler için uygun ortam hidroliz
tepkimelerinde suyun harcanması yani su
ile büyük moleküllerin sindirilmesi
mantığı terlemede vücudun soğutulmasında
görev alması gibi çözücü özelliği
sayesinde artıkların vücuttan
atılabilmesi gibi aslında bir sürü
yaşamsal görevleri ve özellikleri var
suyun Evet bir mola ikin videoda
minerallerden bahsedeceğiz